how old is your daughter now she's very
young she's - yes - what kinds of things
do you do with with her oh I finally
took her to my first the movie you know
dad daughter movie I was driving down
the street and I saw this billboard for
Dumbo and I was like oh I'll take her to
go see Dumbo I didn't know it was a Tim
Burton movie right if you look at the
Billboard it looks like a cartoon I just
thought it still looks like a cartoon so
I show up and it was like IMAX in these
giant LED there chairs I was like wow
they're really going all out for these
kids and I sat down and I gave a she was
sitting there with a big thing of
popcorn she's looking at me she's eating
a big smile on her face and I didn't
dawn on me that we would I was the only
one with the kid there it was like this
60-year old dude sitting next to me and
I was like look at this loser sitting
here by himself go to a kids movie
uh-huh
so then the movie starts and immediately
the music was scary I'm like wow they're
really going Disney's going hard on this
one and my daughter kind of put her arms
up and I just kind of took her in like
you all right and she's she's burying
her face in my neck look I am the guys
being all mean to the elephant I think
was something about zoos you know so
they had to show him being mean he's
like yeah yeah piece of [ __ ] or whatever
you say he said that's a Dumbo we didn't
say but that was his vibe I remember my
daughter said something then the sixty
year old guy gave us a dirty look I'm
like what kind of you know guy gives a
kid a dirty look at a kid's movie and
then it finally dawned on me like you
know this isn't a cartoon like what's
going on here and finally I just said
about eight minutes in I was like - my
daughter's like you want to go home to
mommy and she just goes yeah so I picked
her up when I grabbed the popcorn and I
walked by the 60-year old guy who was
not a loser he is smart enough to know
that it was a real movie you know you
know what I will say as this reminds me
the fact that you were talking to me
once and you said that when you were a
kid your mom would sometimes take you to
inappropriate movies is it at your doing
the same thing to your daughter no he
took she took us to to guees that first
two movies I saw herself for the love of
Benjy which was like I think a talking
dog and then I saw for the Herbie goes
to Monte Carlo which was a Volkswagen
that had a mind of its own mm-hmm and my
mother was just like these movies are
stupid
so we went from that to like stripes and
then we talked her into taking us to see
Scarface I remember that wait how old
are you when you saw scar I was a
freshman I remember this the chainsaw
scene who I loved my mother's to this
day she goes well those first movies
were stupid Scarface is a good movie I
stand by that did that scare you at all
and then no pun intended but that did
like mess you up at all or anything
seeing those I mean that's a young age
to see that stuff now I don't know it's
it's what's your parents to do that's
what messes you up everybody always
tries to say you know are the people
around you the kids you went to school
with everybody tries to say it's
somebody who played on a basketball team
you know cuz they did something that
that message their kids up and it's just
you know it isn't it's you you you
screwed your kid oh yeah